hey guys it is the 17th of January my
name's Jess McDonald and I'm back in the
driver's seat for gamespot news I'm
sorry for the delay I was waiting for
Eddie to get back from holidays and
working on the gist actually I was just
playing link between wells but let's get
on with the news anyway given how much
success steam early access we've given
games like Daisy and rust it seems that
triple-a publishers want in on the
action Ubisoft have brought their
free-to-play shooter Ghost Recon online
to early access this year with the plan
to fine tune the game through the
experience naturally this has evolved
into a debate between those who like the
idea of a transparent development
process and those who aren't happy about
companies particularly loaded triple a
company's being able to sell unfinished
games to people what are often not
insignificant bunches of cash do you
think triple-a publishers should stay
away from steam early access or does it
not really matter to you let me know
what you think respawn has drummed up a
little controversy today by telling
prospective titanfall alpha participants
that they can't share their experiences
publicly the DES called the xbox one
titanfall alpha a limited technical test
and made a point of the fact that it
isn't a beta and there's no news on when
we might be seeing one in the near
future while the studio is strictly not
shareable comments are winging some of
you out it's worth mentioning that a
company putting down the non-disclosure
blanket at this point in development
certainly isn't unheard of do you think
there might be some cause for concern
over the silence titanfall alpha or not
leave me a thought last up GTA isn't
happy with cheetahs so they're going to
hunt you down and run you over with that
car or probably just ban you the dev
have said they might also place players
who create counterfeit GTA online
currency into isolated cheetah pools so
I guess sort of like how England shafted
all they're criminals into Australia but
also not like that at all because we're
awesome
the in-game criminals not to be confused
with all the other end game criminals
who aren't exploiting GTA have been
creating unreasonable amounts of in-game
dollars and messing the experience up
for everybody the counterfeit money is
being removed from the game so if it's
beating up your in-game wallet at the
moment but you aren't one of the money
creating culprits I'd go ahead and spend
it quickly but you didn't hear it from
me go ahead and let me know what you
think of all the GTA money dramas in the
comments down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at Jeff system that's all the
stuff that I have to say to you today
but tomorrow I'll be back with all my
favorite music stuff from the whole week
so be sure to join me again then I'm
just my soul and I hope you have a
lovely thursday